the lack of consequences for elites
and for preferred groups brings about
huge injustices maybe you saw this story
this was a few weeks ago
an 18 year old guy was caught on camera
on a little nighttime camera over a bed
or over a crib
kidnapping and murdering a four-year-old
boy
so he go you can see it's really
terrifying he goes into the the room
nabs this kid out of bed he's sleeping
next to his brother four-year-old boy
and then the boy sometime later is found
beaten to death dead on the street
the suspect's name the suspect who we
saw on camera is
darren ronnelle brown 18 years old
strongly suspected of murdering this
four-year-old boy cash guernin
uh thankfully he's been charged with
capital murder which carries a life
sentence or possibly the death penalty
now how did it get this bad the reason i
bring this up is is not even to talk
about the current charges
obviously the guy deserves to fry
there's no question about it
and it would be good for him to fry it
would be rehabilitative to him to
contemplate his own his own eternal soul
but this isn't the first time that he's
done something like this
this guy darren rennell brown is also
accused of walking into a dallas home
on february 8th and grabbing a young
child the police say he broke in and he
rummaged around
then he punched the homeowner after the
homeowner confronted him
he'd picked up the man's two-year-old
granddaughter the man was able to get
the girl back
and then and this is the weirdest part
the homeowner didn't want to press
charges at the time he told the police
that brown had apologized to him later
now first of all the police should have
pre i mean
the d.a should have pressed charges
anyway no matter what the homeowner
wants
if some guy busts into someone's house
and grabs a two-year-old girl
and then there's an altercation to get
the girl back and then
and then the homeowner says actually
never mind no harm no foul
the d.a it is their responsibility to
press charges
but what you're going to hear from a lot
of the prison reform crowd and all the
people who say actually it was society
that made this guy
beat and kill a four-year-old child or
try to steal a two-year-old child
what they're gonna say is look we need
mercy we're a merciful and compassionate
society
and in our mercy and our compassion
we're gonna let this guy off the hook
where's the mercy and compassion for
cass garnet where's the mercy and
compassion for his family
where's the mercy and compassion for
this two-year-old girl
that thankfully he didn't manage to
steal her
where's that mercy and compassion
these are real consequences here but
because
i'm frankly i'm shocked that they
released the guy's
description all right that's going to
advance harmful stereotypes right
according to the austin statesman
it's gonna you're not allowed to do that
but this has
horrible the the bizarre racial
narrative
that the left has grabbed on to in this
country is having
horrible effects for people of all races
for justice in the country
and it doesn't matter no consequences
what's no there'll be no consequences
for the d.a who didn't push charges
none at all i hope there are
consequences for this this
guy darren ronell brown maybe there will
be maybe there won't
now the the racial narrative that
they're pushing of course
is uh that as the commenter observed at
the top of the show
that whiteness is a sort of stand-in for
sin and that's why it's a we need a
permanent cure to it
and we need to abolish it and this is
what we're told now in may in corporate
boardrooms in university campuses
there is legal anti-white racism
hey hold on i know i know that you're in
a hurry to go
pre-order my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which will be on pre-order for another
eight days or so and then it's gonna be
released on june 22nd you can get an
autographed first edition copy right now
i know you're in a rush
but first just ring that bell subscribe
like
this video head on over subscribe to the
mike and all show audio podcast where we
get your podcasts
then you will never miss any of our
content all right you can go get the
[Music]
book
[Music]
you